[Applause]
this is exciting what a great crowd
thank you for being here this is very
nice of you yeah well good night
everybody the uh easily pleased crowd
when a crowd's as happy to see you go as
they are to see you show up that's a bad
sign uh did you just mention bla that
there is going to be drinks for the
crowd after the show that's right why
not drinks why not drinks before and
during the show what's wrong with that
next time next time we're always
learning and once again they've added
another row that's true first time we
did this here at the Sirius XM garage it
was just this audience here then I said
I think we could have more that's right
so they added one row I said I think it
could be more they added one more row
none of you would be here were it not
for me that's true that's absolutely
true none of you would be here Hi how
are you I love your hair and the Hi how
are you
hi I was bullied
um I don't think you were you seem too
cool uh yeah anyway oh and look at that
that's a that's a late night with con
O'Brien shirt those are made of as
bestus be
careful those are not yeah yeah we just
took old like er shirts and Friends
shirts and spray painted them yeah have
you ever worn it in the rain they catch
fire true story yeah yeah all the cone
and merch yeah don't wear it that stuff
is uh not that one that one's cool
yeah uh no it's very nice to be here we
have a a great show we have such a good
show very excited very good show very
good show tonight excited I like that
you paused for a long time before you
brought me out as if it was a big
mystery yeah you went and now it's time
to bring out and there was this long
weird pause well I had and I thought you
had gas or something you were just it
was this long like who could it be
everyone here knows well yeah we we want
the anticipation people frothing at the
mouth I shouldn't have said frothing at
the mouth but you know the anticipation
High yeah what you described is
botulism sorry a lot of Conan fans have
by the way thank you for coming so far
I'm just going to assume you all came
from a really great distance did anyone
come from very where did you come from
Long Beach Oh Long
Beach come on I was hoping you'd say
like
Guam we took 11 planes and a submarine
and then a
hovercraft no but you came from Long
Beach well that's what is that that's
about 35
minutes wow Die Hard fans I have the
Guam of California yeah it is the Guam
of California it really is well thank
you what's your name Ty hi Ty it's nice
to meet you yeah how are you and you
have your friends with you here or you
just here by great oh great so you all
came together from Long Beach who really
came from a great distance who came from
Far Far Away yes
Riverside
Riverside so that would be like 39
minutes we're seeing here the depth and
the intensity of Conan
fandom people come oh I don't even want
to I see you raising your hand and I
don't even want to know oh Northwest
Hollywood yes go ahead my apartment
building is attached to this
no your apartment building is
attached you literally slid down a
pole like a fireman to get here and you
look you're wearing pajamas you were you
were asleep 11 minutes ago and you're
like I don't want to see Conan but I
guess I'll see his
guest right down into a seat do you come
see a lot of serious shows this my first
one this is your first one the first one
that enticed you out of your apartment
that's 18 in from where I'm standing
right now you should have a party for
all of us after the show we should all
go back to your
apartment what's that will I
come no I will not I've got to get back
to Riverside cuz that's also where I
live we'll see we'll see how it goes
we'll see how good a crowd you are if
you're a really good crowd who knows man
stop by although when a man my age who's
married with grown children shows up at
a party it can be
misunderstood it can come across as a
little creepy what's he doing here he
just invited himself you know I've
talked for a long time uh and really I
should uh invite out the true stars of
the show I'm just kidding but uh I do
love them and together I think we might
we make quite a team I'm going to bring
them out right now Sonam messian and Mr
Matt gorley let's get them out
here
[Music]
yay y
s oh my God now why did you push your uh
you pushed your crotchal area towards me
as you hugged me which was weird and UPS
setting but anyway that's your own
choice recoiling my own face you're
recoiling your face but then what
happened well anyway let's not talk
about it it'll all be discussed at the
trial uh I'm going to now this is
something it's very difficult to do in
my business switch from this mic to that
mic it's a very difficult procedure but
when you're dealing with a professional
it can be quite easily
done I was warming up the crowd and it
turns out there might be a part
happening after the show all right
inches from where we're sitting right
now son okay yeah and son likes to party
I do I you know what earlier I was in
the bathroom with a bunch of these guys
and I leaned up um on the sink and it
was wet and my butt is completely wet
right now and so when I came in I wait a
minute that's the seat where our guest
is going to sit yes our guest is going
to sit and uh what a crappy show we have
it's okay it's SpongeBob SquarePants
okay good yeah our first guest SpongeBob
will immediately take care of the
problem yeah with his spongy ass um why
were you hanging out in the bathroom
with the crowd beforehand what kind of
show business is this I don't know she
was in the bathroom of that lady's
apartment yeah oh I see I went to her
house was everyone in this crowd hanging
out in that woman's ma'am uh Miss what
is ma'am I call her ma'am like him in a
1930s Oklahoma Vaudeville
sketch what is your name Young lady
Emily Emily all right Emily's having a
party in her apartment above the Sirius
XM afterwards uh and Sony you'll
probably go you'll go to
anything why did you say it like that
because you will if you find out that
the the the snacks and the drinks are
free you're there yeah actually that is
true I like to I love how you
immediately every time I do this with
Sona she'll be like what what do you
mean and I'll restate the thing I just
said and she go that's true yeah that's
you're right if if there is free food
and free drinks I'll be there but also I
just like to be included I like when
people invite me to things that's nice
well she didn't invite you yet she
invited most of the crowd I think she's
doing a thing with her hand so I'm going
to do it uh well listen I found out from
the crowd cuz I always like to find out
and people really came from all over the
globe and when I say Globe if it was a
globe that was shrunk down to the size
of roughly a 15 milei radius of Los
Angeles a globe that size but we have
people from uh Riverside here Riverside
is not close yeah no that's not easy and
you uh you came all the way from
Altadena okay Conan it's not they don't
even use American currency there it's I
swear to God it's all Armenian currency
um Armenian where where people were
wooing Alena I think that's good I I
wasn't saying anything bad about it I
was just saying it's amazing it's
incredible that you live in aladas why
is it Armenian currency I don't um I
don't know cuz there a lot of your
family there you have can you name what
the Armenian currency is
yeah The The J the
okay the the didam but what the did yeah
what you just it's the d d we went
together remember I know right I don't
see you throwing a lot of DB around what
do you mean I wouldn't throw it you
threw it around when we were there I
didn't pay for anything that's true you
pay for things I was cool with going
with you yeah I pay for everything it's
very true anyway people from all over
the all over Los Angeles are here
it's very cool and I'm very thrilled
that they're all here and Matt I'm
excited about the show we have a
terrific show today we're going to have
a very good time and uh how are you I
didn't get to really chat with you yet
I'm good I'm good Sona and I got here
way too early so we went over to the 99
cent store across the street to see if
everything actually is 99 we did do that
though yeah yeah no when Matt said it I
didn't
think you're way too cool to do that no
I thought of course you did that no one
here is like what the fonds went to the
99 cent
store but anyway so is it what did you
find out I forgot to mention that we're
starting a new trend yeah so what did
you find out that hardly anything is
priced at 99 a lot of it has gone up to
a19 yeah um but there's still a few
items that are still 99 cent that's no
America I want to live in if you're
calling at the 99 cent store then I
think it should cost 99 Cents or below
once it's a $119 I think I want to move
to a foreign land like TOA you know some
place far away where I'm protected all
right um You won't be protected there I
will your family your family loves me I
mean yeah against their better judment
after everything you've said about my
dad's mustache he still like really
likes you he made a doll that came to
life he's
Pinocchio he's an amazing I love jetto
uh so what's the story what uh you know
you're you see you went to the here's
what I did they told me you have to wait
uh back here where the crowd won't see
you and I said said okay and I thought
they were leading me to a dressing room
and they led me to the garage at
SiriusXM I'm not talking about SiriusXM
garage like this is the garage it's a
real garage how long were you and my car
is there like 20 minutes oh so I just
sat on my car and watched other cars
come and go and people would just wave
at me and I go yeah hi they' be like
look it's it's the girl from the Wendy's
logo and I'd go
Hi how are you nice to see you and I
thought this is this is where I am in
Show Business I'm sitting on the trunk
of my car in a garage you're such a big
celebrity you bet the biggest the very
biggest